dites donc est-ce que c'est tous les
moutons bêlent et je mets les approches
bâle doit toucher la lettre à menton
thurella part pas dans quel quartier
avait quartier de la forêt tropicale
entre variétés ang regarder les caméras
surveillant de total y est tout ça est
passionnant adrien parce que les trois
fabricants de culte était rarement des
choses aussi excitant pourtant juif
l'adjointe au maire deux autopsies dont
je ne fais que du secrétariat améliorer
et je pense que le maire vous d'obtenir
le vote des moutons mais il m'a offert
cette volte face
c'est donc cette entreprise choix des
tissus renom rigolo qui m'a donné une
fois moi je les appelais prout de lyon
une fois il n'a pas du tout apprécié
j'ai vraiment passé un sale quart
d'heure oui mais si la mairie
vous me direz si vous trouvez quelque
chose c'était vraiment chouette pour moi
tu crois que le soir elles se comptent
elles mêmes pour s'endormir à tétouan